du canada les jaune et noir se vend plus
et justement ils vont retourner le mall
sur leurs 7 et vous rien car ce sont des
génies des génies de la cuisine de la
cuite à la moustache
attention il va se transformer chez vous
dépêchez-vous dépression l'unification
valentino rossi tous les costumes et
continuer
énormément pour retourner le vol et la
loi vous ne prenez rien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
attention vous ne retourne non seulement
ces morts
[Applaudissements]
moi
tu verras l'ont élu most
sa carrière
[Applaudissements]
comme jamais en six mois
merci
pas la peine de faire le test
[Applaudissements]
si vous venez alors bravo parce que vous
avez été plutôt très trop regarder juste
une technique vous prenez bien le
truvada et vous faites comme ça wajoka
comme ça si vous mettez comme ça les
regarde et vois est compté jusqu'à 10,2
sur cette rumeur
[Applaudissements]
cette démence et or l autre plan enfin
et ça va mal c'est déjà bien
ouais j'aime bien merci bon bah oui j'ai
gagné merci